you're accustomed to going out on Friday
nights and Saturday nights and Thursday
night ladies night and maybe sleeping in
a little bit and maybe working five
o'clock you come home you watch all the
games all the playoff games all the
soccer matches all the football games
you get every one of those things
because it's your lifestyle your boys
call you on Friday night because you
have this one spot you go to Saturday
night it's your favorite three lounges
that you go to Sunday you have a spot
you go to from 8 o'clock to 1 o'clock in
the morning go to sleep at 1:30 so you
can get some rest to wake up at 7
o'clock in the morning you have all your
spots that you do let me prepare you all
this is gonna change your
relationship with some of your friends
is gonna change your daily habits is
gonna change some of the people were
hanging out with before it's gonna
change some of the places used to go to
before it's gonna change generally this
most people cannot handle because they
want to they want to win big as an
entrepreneur and become a hero on
celebrity and all this stuff but they
want to keep this lifestyle so it's
almost like they're not letting go this
to go get this you have to let go the
lifestyle and if you can't let go this
lifestyle if you cannot wear multiple
hats if you cannot understand that
competition is gonna want to put you out
of business if you don't pay attention
to tax